first and foremost I'd like to offer our
condolences to the family and friends
the pilot who was killed in this tragic
accident
and I also like to offer my sincere
gratitude for the outstanding work help
and cooperation
New York Police Department fire
department of New York
emergency management office the office
of the chief medical examiner
apartment buildings Federal Bureau of
Investigation FAA is a building
management company Commonwealth partners
yesterday we form a team to investigate
this accident involving an Augusta
1:09 twin-engine helicopter which
crashed on the roof 787 7th Avenue
yesterday afternoon there's not a
heliport located on top of the bill
the investigative team includes Leonardo
helicopters Pratt Whitney of Canada and
the Federal Aviation Administration
our mission is to gather the facts and
ultimately determine the probable cause
of this accident and make
recommendations to prevent similar
accidents from
this morning we met the first responders
in our investigative team set the scope
on seed examination
some of the information we know said or
said the helicopter departed the pilot
and one passenger from Westchester
County yesterday about 11:30 a.m. and
landed in Manhattan at 11:45 a.m.
passengers disembark pilot waited for
Street helipad until about 1:30 he
departed for his destination and Linden
New Jersey
this morning I visited the accident
scene the wreckage is combined to the
rooftop it is a highly fragmented
crash fire consumed much directed
we begin our scene documentation
focusing on preserving perishable
evidence such as records condition
witness statements records and video
we have much more work to do before this
investigation is complete we should be
Gus gathering records about the pilot
the helicopter whether an environment
times the accident
we've already begun our witness
interviews several witnesses have been
already interviewed including the
passenger on the previous flight staff
at 34th Street helipad more witness
interviews ongoing now and plan anyone
who saw or heard or known as anything
about this play
should contact us at the following email
address witness at NTSB duck duck after
the on-scene documentation is complete
the records will be moved to a secure
location for a more detailed examination
for the remainder of
yes yes people not determine the
profitable cause while on scene or
speculate about the cause or the
circumstances of this accident
you can expect a preliminary report
summarizing the facts gathered while we
were here
in about two weeks the NTSB gov website
or will also not contain the calls to
summarize the facts gathered we've got
time for a few questions
not too many I've got to get back to
work and hold on one second I want to
give you before I forget for all the
questions I don't get to or can't answer
because I don't have that information
right now you need to contact NTSB mr.
Terry Williams
2:02
three one four 6100
it's an excellent question helicopter
was not installed doctor question pardon
flight data recorder were not installed
on the helicopter
they're not required however there is
instrumentation and helicopter systems
that do have memory independent
capability to rework we're searching for
those on the rooftop right now
can you talk more about the weather the
NYPD's aviation unit
well that's something that we're looking
into I've not reviewed the records but
it's certainly one of the most
interesting concerns we have is
gathering as much information about the
weather should the helicopter have been
flying they don't know yet
we've got some information that says
that the pilot may have tried to make
radio calls near the end of the flight
we're trying to confirm that now we're
trying to find out difference reported
and it's not reported find out what
witnesses recall from that radio
transmission if it existed we've heard
about this
as far as we know the pilot was not in
communicate
nor did he was he required to contact
ATC for his plan through the flight take
this route flight and not go as planned
and they have ventured into airspace
requiring that
at the moment we don't have any records
of the news
[Music]
yes and no the plan is to get me into
helicopter off the roof as soon as
possible but we still need to look at
some of the most of the items before
that moving begins
I hope the moving begins this afternoon
or this evening it's going to be very
challenging salvage company responsible
is upon their there in round right now
how they're going to get it bound is for
them to determine it maybe down the
stairs and down the elevators
I do but I forgot
investigations like this generally take
between 18 and 24 months we've got a new
target to try to get this down in 15
months I hope I can do that I can't
you don't have the details of that
conversation but what I've been told for
the interview with the passenger on the
previous flight is that there was
toxicology tests are something that we
normally do in all fatal accident
investigations at the NTSB and we plan
to
[Music]
I haven't seen that video I've heard
about it
laughter it's something that I still
have
roughly 45 to 1
he was waiting and I don't know waiting
for the weather
reviewing the weather we're looking at
the weather
during question
I understand that they're not that this
flight was not required to nor was
intended to be
when you can't put their traffic control
so per se there isn't the clearance this
entitles decision in Clinton Department
when each other
I don't have any attorney
[Music]
we don't have any information about the
pilots conversations at the FBO just yet
we have interviewed some
so what he said if anything something I
don't know do two more
well all investigations are somewhat
challenging I'd have to say that the
location within the city and on top of
the roof of the building is probably the
biggest challenge one more sir are you
saying that he had conversations with
the heliport ground control you just
don't know what they were yes and no the
information that we've been provided
with is that radio transmissions were
made from the helicopter to who I don't
know
and they actually occur that's the last
question I can take today thank you for
your thank you for your we're not going
to have another one today whether or not
we have one tomorrow will be answered by
mr. Terry Williams you've got this
number
that's it thank you very much